j'entends d'une partie de l'extrême
gauche l'argument suivant vous dites il
n'aurait pas fallu mettre des policiers
et des gendarmes parce que vous savez
que ce serait violent et qu'après tout
ce ne sont et que ce ne sont que des
biens
c'est très intéressant ça veut dire que
d'abord vous refusez le droit de
propriété personne ne dit que ces
pauvres agriculteurs il est méchants
tout le monde a foulé leur chant comme
on foulerait votre jardin si on ferait
votre jardin je pense que vous
considérez que ce n'est pas tout à fait
je parle pas de vous madame il était je
parle en général je reviendrai après sur
votre question je regarderai sur votre
question mais c'est intéressant parce
que philosophiquement je pense que ça
sous-tend beaucoup de nos désaccords
vous dites il y aurait donc des
confrontations il y aura des
manifestants blessés puisqu'il y aura de
la violence et donc il faudrait pour les
biens pour des bassines pour des trous
éventuellement pour d'autres bien il
faudrait pas y mettre des policiers des
gendarmes après tout ça a été dit tout à
l'heure à la cantonade c'était un trou
bon non mais c'est pas bah oui c'est une
propriété privée alors après ça dépend
si on considère que la propriété c'est
du vol ou c'est pas du vol deuxièmement
il y a eu des décillions de justice le
rôle de la police gendarmerie c'est
d'appliquer les décisions de justice
c'est d'appliquer des scions de justice
on n'a pas à dire si le juge a eu raison
il y a eu des décisions de justice les
bassines c'était un outil c'est un outil
pour les agriculteurs tout le monde
oublie les agriculteurs aujourd'hui mais
c'est eux qui sont harcelés pour une
partie d'entre eux pour une partie
d'entre eux les agriculteurs ont été
harcelés attaqué allez on va écouter les
réponses du ministre s'il vous plaît
et l'objectif qui avait été défini
c'était non seulement de détruire les
bassines et les préparations des
bassines mais d'occuper le site par une
donne un endroit et vous savez si jamais
les dirigeants correspondu arriver les
Ultra gauche à Notre-Dame-des-Landes
avaient eu le même réaction que ce
gouvernement si il y aurait pas eu Notre
Dame des Landes il y aurait pas eu de
contre-société et il y aurait pas eu le
désastre pour l'autorité de l'État qui a
été Notre-Dame-des-Landes parce que
Notre-Dame-des-Landes nourrit d'autres
contestations d'ultra gauche et donc oui
et oui les policiers et les gendarmes
sont là pour protéger les biens et pas
simplement les personnes et pour faire
respecter les décisions de justice et ne
nous appartient pas de penser que notre
opinion personnelle est supérieure à
décision de justice